チェーン今はこんなに切ってるけど中学校の時はクラスの隅っこに言いましたはじめ者
等で最近せーのなんかがくせいじゃないどんなのだったかなと思い出したんですけど
あの僕結構ですね
小学校中学校が暗黒時代で行こうよ皆さんと同じ学校に入ると結構惹かれるような
インキャポジションにいましたあの真面目っぽいんだけどまぁ
頭も悪い目立たない教室の隅っこにいる友達が少ない
授業中も発言しない提出物は忘れる女子と喋れない
もうそういうの結構少痛って結構そんな感じだったんですよ
まあたまにモテ期が来たんですけどねあそのも時も一緒に終わり結構ほぼほぼ
小学校中学校は暗黒時代調印者のせきていた僕なんですけども小中学校の時ですね
同級生とか先輩は後輩が見たんですけどもやっぱ
4四半期なのかわかんないんですけど特徴的に中学生が多いんですよね結構ついて不正
なヤンキーとか僕見てるの好きでちょっと不合邦中学生の中特徴的な部分をちょっと皆
さんに今日お伝えして共感を得られたりとか見たことがあるなとか思ってくれたが
ありがたいと思いますでは
うぇっ
中学生かもよん
あの授業が
ナビなぁ
すいませんぱいうわぁお店がはまあどうしたーー
[音楽]
ブーブー一間
暗い方が凄いのシーズゲーセン際500いや
ルーニー区間は雷や資源下げてくんの
ん
何がん
リズムがん
ていません
e re
[音楽]
ん
ブーバーし
うっぽい
うんこ混ぜて熊さんん
[音楽]
ブービー中学校で一番 to do
ああああああん
酵素とポコノでこんな発車
植わる
いますはいはいはいおっカラー
公安フェンダーやどうだ
うるさいん
そうロケグスンホテルのまま声これええやー
none
ああああああああああっ
はぁっ
もう一回
背景かっこいいよね
遠方のに見てるんで言う今
えってん坊
フェインポンッ
勉強症デー婚を包囲
王子 make ねー
銀行年収がとっ好きですよだああああ
[音楽]
ハッハー
par 50
[拍手]
夜はてまいりましてメッス薄いて当たるが俺よりた
母
はっはっはっはっはー
jr
re ん
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
あああ
ここの胃袋法4ついい一体だよえっ
[音楽]
ん
ちょっと視野せまだまだマナカナだ
答えは茶を作ってあってお前は今月守っていての前
うんいいよって言われた
先生
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
バッハ
[音楽]
ん
おっしゃるポロリさーんん
僕乗ってりゃローザ強いっすよいい枚強が強くねあーんでもさぁ員にさーんカー
チャーハン枚サーカーチャンに思い立ってた9時になったらさーああ夏もう取り上げろ
それとマヤーした
じゃんそれでクール pop 女性まぁちょっとまあ4 my 路線ですね金ゲットし
カバー終わったところそれじゃねーぞまあそりゃあヨッシャーシっもわー
しかも猫のうスーパー強い増ダメージを受ければダメ受けるかはい教養
乗ってね銭婆課金できねもうれはい完成
ネイロスよねっロス病デー
動画をいくつですか第か中ですねん
待って勝ち10日中ってまあ質問はそもそもさ
端を持ってなびねって最もスパイだっていっかかあちゃんなんて行ってないですよね
飲んだジャンが入ってモス最もすごい絶テンのなくお母さんキーといっても
オッペンじゃないんでえーぜってーを超えて知ったかだよと子さんですねいやっほひと
かさぞや
じゃあじゃあ恋しちゃったどうか確かめる家具だよ
んじゃあローサのあの服装はどんな女でしょうーそんなの友美と合法分くらい焼くそれ
ら海は俺はよね
1たいですぞ問題児いるんでしょ
そんなにも65
もうこりゃも知った衣で競ったはございません
ここでしょうっ
を知っていますでお前てもぜっ5位いやさんはお前そういう俺たちドウメイクっていう
のにさーんだよ
そういうよく寝はないんだよ
謎言われたぽんちもんや俺たちやをの中学高等女ちゃうんだよ
損なのさ俺だぁずっちゃんとさ
ウソつかずにやってるんでさぁお前だけどゲームスマホ後ってねえのいい嘘ついたら
いいいやさんこれからじゃ遅いんじゃ嘘じゃんじゃないよねー
うーん端を持って23ちゃって
持っじゃあもう今日問題ですかこれは買った方近場でないそれじゃあ
ブロッドのキャラを三大名前言ってください
うん
モンスターの強化ですかうん
んんん
いっぽいん
よなもう持ってく奴絶対はない被害者を奪われてるじゃん
ピザ屋でも言わないとやってるか言ってるかねやっぱ
大丈夫なんだろうか本文やっうわーこれじゃべ予約わー
ua
どうねぇねぇどんな部屋もと自分この通りに沿っと思いますやべ
終わった
チーズ4
ぺっぺージで自慰し
約4
実施たんだね手を振っスザクはだった